All right.
So that's supervised learning and
unsupervised learning.
That's pretty good.
The last one is reinforcement learning.
>> [SOUND].
>> Now reinforcement learning
is what we both do, so
Michael does a little bit of
reinforcement learning here and there.
You've got how many papers published
in reinforcement learning?
>> All of them.
[LAUGH] Several.
I have several.
>> The man has like a hundred papers of
reinforcement learnings and in fact he
wrote with his colleagues the great
summary journal article bringing every
one up to date on what reinforcement
learning was like back in 1990.
>> Yeah like 112 years ago.
>> 1992.
>> People are saying yeah we should
probably somebody should write a new one
because the other ones getting
a little long in the dude.
>> But there's been books written
on machine learning system.
>> That's right.
>> It's a very popular field.
That's why we're both in it.
Michael tends to prove a lot of things,.
>> It is not, that is not why I'm in it.
>> What, I didn't, wait, what?
>> You said it's a very popular
field and that's why we're in it.
>> No, no, no, no, no.
Did I say that?
>> That's what I heard.
>> I didn't mean to say that.
>> [SOUND] Let's run it back and see.
>> It's a very popular, yeah,
let's do that again because
I did not mean to say that.
It is a very popular field.
Perhaps because you're in it Michael.
>> I don't think that's it.
When I was an undergraduate,
I thought the thing that I
really want to understand.
I liked AI,
I liked the whole idea of AI.
But what I really want to understand
is how can you learn to be
better from experience?
And like I, I built a tic-tac-toe
playing program, and like,
I want this tic-tac-toe playing program
to get really good at tic-tac-toe.
because I was always interested
in the most practical society
impacting problems.
>> I think that generalized
pretty well to world hunger.
>> Eventually.
So so that is what got
me interested in it, and
I was, I didn't even know what
it was called for a long time.
So I started doing
reinforcement learning, and
then discovered that it was
interesting and popular.
>> Right.
Well, I certainly wouldn't suggest that
we're doing the science that we're doing
because it's popular.
We're doing it because
we're interested in it.
>> Yes.
>> And I'm interested in reinforcement
learning because in some sense,
it kind of encapsulates all
the things I happen to care about.
I come from a sort of general AI
background, and I care modeling people.
I care about building smart agents
that have to live in in world that
other smart agents, thousands of them,
hundreds of thousand of them,
thousands of them.
Some of them might be human and
have to feel some way to
predict what to do over time.
So, from a sort a technical point
of view, if we can think of re,
in, supervised learning as
function approximation and
unsupervised learning as, you know.
>> Concise-
>> Concise,
impact description, what's
the difference between something like
reinforcement learning and those two?
Supervised learning.
>> So often the way that
supervised learning oh, sorry,
reinforcement learning is described is,
is learning from delayed reward.
>> Mm-hm.
So instead of the feedback that you get
in supervised learning which
is here's what you should do.
And the feedback that you get in
unsupervised learning which is
the feedback in reinforcement
learning may come several steps
after the decisions that
you've actually made.
>> So a good example of that, or
the easy example of that would be,
actually your tic-tac-toe program,
right?
So, you do something in tic-tac-toe,
you put an X in the center and
then you put a, let's say,
an O over here.
>> Oh.
>> And then I put an X right here.
>> Nice.
>> And then you ridiculously
put an O in the center.
>> Which allows me to put
an X over here and I win.
>> All right.
>> Now what's interesting about that is,
I didn't tell you what happened until
the very end when I said X wins.
>> Right.
And now I know I made a mistake
somewhere along the way but
I don't know exactly where.
I may have to kind of roll back the game
in my mind and eventually figure out
where it is that I went off track,
and what it is that I did wrong.
>> And in the full generality
of reinforcement learning,
you may have never made a mistake.
It may simply be that's
the way games go but
you would like to know which of
the moves you made mattered.
Now, if it were a civilized learning
problem, I would have put the X here,
he would have put the O there, and
it would have been called that's Good.
I would have put the X here, and
when he put the O there, it would have
been that's Bad, the O goes here.
>> Mm-hm.
Right.
>> Or something like that.
It would have told you where
he should have put the O.
But here, all he gets is eventually
some kind of signal saying,
you did something well.
You did something poorly and even
then it's only relative to the other
signals that you might have gotten.
>> Right, so then reinforcement
learning is in some sense harder
because nobody's telling you what to do.
You have to work it out on your own.
>> Yeah it's like playing a game
without knowing any of the rules.
Or at least knowing how you win or lose.
But being told every once in awhile that
you've won or you've lost, okay, now-
>> Sometimes I feel like that.
>> I know man.